welcome to fundamentals of qualitative
research methods my name is Leslie
Currie I'm a senior research scientist
at the Yale School of Public Health a
co-director at the Robert Wood Johnson
clinical Scholars Program at the Yale
School of Medicine and a lecturer at
Yale College and in all these various
roles I have the opportunity to teach
and mentor students in using qualitative
research methods as well as collaborate
across a number of multidisciplinary
teams across the university I'd like to
give you an overview of the modules in
this series and to start with the goal
of the series is to enhance our capacity
to conceptualize design and conduct
qualitative research in the Health
Sciences and by Health Sciences I mean
clinical and health services research
implementation science across a host of
disciplines and specialties there are
six modules in the series the first is
what is qualitative research the second
moves us to developing a qualitative
research question which is actually not
as easy as it might sound the third
module addresses one of the major
qualitative study designs the use of
in-depth interviews the fourth module
reviews a second major qualitative study
design the use of focus groups the fifth
module provides an overview of
qualitative data analysis the principles
and practices of analyzing qualitative
data and the last module reviews the
principles of scientific rigor in
qualitative research and so to begin
with the first module what is
qualitative research I want to invite
you to take a moment to reflect on this
fundamental premise really appreciating
this assumption is necessary in order to
maximize the use of qualitative methods
in the Health Sciences so this is a
quote attributed to Albert Einstein who
reflected that not everything that
can be counted counts and not everything
that counts can be counted so if you
pause and you think of a circumstance or
an issue or a phenomenon in your own
clinical practice or area of research I
invite you to contemplate a phenomenon
that perhaps can't have a number
assigned to it if we're interested for
instance in end-of-life care for
terminally ill patients you might think
about preferences for services at the
end of life this may be something that
it was very difficult to put a number on
and so this assumption helps us
appreciate the potential power of
qualitative methods so as an example we
might be interested in the care of
patients with epilepsy this first
question is a quantitative question what
proportion of people with epilepsy stop
taking their medications for three
consecutive days in a six-month period
this is something that we can quantify
put a number on it can be very important
in an overall question and looking at
adherence for meant to medication
regimes in this patient group a
different question related to the same
phenomenon might be how does medication
shape the lives of people with epilepsy
and so looking at a very different
perspective for the patient experience
whether or not they feel mastery or self
efficacy in trying to adhere to complex
medication regimes so let's move to a
definition what is qualitative research
there are many definitions this is one
that we feel represents the critical
elements of a qualitative research
approach and so we'll work through this
through this definition together for a
minute qualitative research is a
strategy for the systematic collection
organization and interpretation of
textual information so let's break this
down into parts we use the word strategy
to connote the fact that qualitative
research question is thoughtful
deliberate
conceived of with a broader attention to
context and to the relative strengths
and limitations of a qualitative method
so it's strategic in its nature it's
systematic it's not something that's
loose loosely formed ad hoc it rather
relies on a set of established
well-defined articulated methodologies
for the collecting organizing and
analyzing of qualitative data
qualitative research broadly uses
inductive approaches so working from the
ground up to generate novel insights
into phenomena that are difficult to
measure quantitatively such as
preferences for end-of-life care or
issues of self-efficacy and mastery in
self-care management so qualitative
methods can do a couple of things two
broad buckets the first being generating
a comprehensive description of processes
mechanisms or settings so thinking about
processes of implementing clinical care
mechanisms how one intervention may
achieve a particular outcome or settings
what is it like to care for patients and
their families in a particular
environment these methods can also
characterize participant perspectives
and their experiences in great depth
here we might think about individual
health behaviors individual experiences
of care in a particular clinic setting
so want to spend a few minutes on this
figure here in this Venn diagram we see
on one in one circle qualitative in the
other circle quantitative we have arrows
pointing to the center of the
intersection of these circles in order
to convey the really I think very
critical notion that quantitative and
qualitative methods really exist along a
continuum of measurement that each has
its respective strengths and limitations
and that when we draw upon those two in
order to minimize
the limitations in a particular method
and maximize its assets we use mix we
can use mixed methods which is the
combining of qualitative and
quantitative methods so let's just
populate one of these circles on the
qualitative methods circle so I
mentioned qualitative methods in terms
of approach is inductive in nature so
we're not coming to a research question
with any a priori hypotheses that we're
testing we're rather working from the
ground up qualitative research in terms
of its goal is to achieve depth of
understanding so we're looking in a very
deep way to unpack critical facets of a
given phenomenon we may be interested in
generating a hypotheses that can then go
on and be tested in a quantitative study
qualitative work occurs in a natural
setting it's not experimental it's not
controlled it doesn't happen in a lab
rather we're often interested in
features of the natural environment that
may help us understand the question of
interest sampling approaches and
qualitative methods are purposeful in
nature so just take a moment here to
think together about what purposeful
means this is in contrast to random
sampling so rather than for instance
were in an emergency department setting
and we are rather than recruit every
fifth patient who comes through the
doors of the emergency department a
purposeful sampling design would choose
individual patients who come through the
door that share a given characteristic
so for instance if we're interested in
the care of patients who are homeless in
the emergency department setting we'd
want to be very purposeful in that
design and choosing only those who have
the experience that we're interested in
studying data collection in qualitative
methods is done through interview guides
and various kinds of observation tools
these are much more open-ended than
structured surveys or instrumentation we
use in our quantitative studies and
lastly data analysis is iterative it's a
process of interpreting data going out
to the field collecting data
interpreting that going back out to the
field collecting day
and interpreting that this is in
contrast to our approaches in for
instance a structured survey on
quantitative methods where we collect
all of the data and then begin our
analysis only at that point and so you
can see how the quality principles of
qualitative methods line up with a
quantitative methods and I think very
important to consider that these are
simply a range of tools all designed to
measure different aspects of phenomena
of interest so what are the products of
qualitative research what can we make of
this well there are four at least four
ways to think about what we generate
through qualitative methods the first
product is recurrent themes or
hypotheses we're going to look at an
example of that in a moment the second
kind of product might be a survey
instrument measure so using a
qualitative exploratory phase in order
to design a survey to measure something
that hasn't been measured previously
taxonomy these are classification
systems in order to identify essential
properties of a particular construct and
conceptual models or theories these are
frameworks for helping us understand a
particular phenomenon these are four
major products of qualitative research
the most common we see in the health
sciences are recurrent themes or
hypotheses so themes are unifying
concepts or statements and they can do a
couple of things the first is to help us
identify and characterize a number of
aspects of health care and health the
first can be patterns of behaviors we
might look at how patterns recur in a
certain patient population or in a
certain environment they can help us
understand group interactions and
individual perceptions themes also can
help us develop testable hypotheses they
can do this by helping identify the
salient factors what matters in a given
to a given question what matters say
from a patient's perspective and they
can help inform predictions about
relationships how to
specs or dimensions of a given question
might relate to one another
so it's good let's look at an example
this is a paper written by a former
clinical scholar at the Robert Wood
Johnson program Lisa diamond and Lisa
was very interested in the use of
interpreters by resident physician
physicians in caring for patients who
have limited English proficiency and so
Lisa conducted a qualitative study she
interviewed residents at two academic
medical centers with excellent
interpreter services on site and she
talked with the residents to understand
their experience in using interpreters
in these environments in order to care
for these for these patients this is an
excerpt from the published paper which
is in the Journal of general internal
medicine and this is to give you an
example of what a fee Matic output looks
like this theme is in is in bold this is
one of the five recurrent themes in the
paper and the primary theme here the
emphasis is to indicate that residents
physicians
recognize that they under use
professional interpreters and describe
this phenomenon as quote getting by
sometimes we use the language of
participants in order to represent the
key element the most pertinent essence
of a given theme and then what follows
is several sentences that describe that
theme in greater depth and then followed
by an illustrative quote so using the
words of participants in order to
support and illustrate the higher-level
theme and just to read this together
this theme this quote from a resident
said that I know that when people are
very pushed for time they may or may not
call an interpreter they may just get by
on the few words they know in different
languages for like pain and take a deep
breath and just fumble through you
probably get a pretty bad history and
not maybe a great and maybe not a great
physical exam either it's an example of
thematic output so let's conclude with a
few thoughts first qualitative method
can provide unique contributions to
health services and clinical research
we've talked through briefly some
examples in this introductory segment
second there are rigorous and widely
accepted procedures for study design
sampling data collection and data
analysis and qualitative research and in
the remaining five modules in this
series we'll talk more about primary
methodologies interviews and focus
groups and data analysis in that context
thank you